from time to time we do a draft here on
pft live usually it is a two-man
operation today with dan katz aka
barstool big cat and chris sims in
stanford and me here in west virginia
we're going to try a three-man
three-round draft and i'm gonna sit out
the coin toss guys i get to preside over
this which is fine because it's rigged
anyway
dan and chris are going to participate
dan gets to call it since he's the new
guy call it in the virtual air heads or
tails okay i'm calling tails tails never
fails oh that's that's my never ever
friend okay good good here we go
here we go it always comes up tails okay
there it is he's already figured out
it's
always tails all right i'm going to
defer to chris he's deferring to me
okay it's like i'm patrick mahomes give
me the ball uh oh you don't know what
happens here all right i'm going uh
right off the bat i'm going in that
kansas city football game most
non-important qb to me is tyree kill uh
i'm gonna pick him right off the bat
just because i think he can dictate so
much of what the patriots do and how to
find different ways not only to use them
as a decoy to stretch the field and
really you know back off that patriots
defense to a degree but also the other
factors like we saw last week i mean he
ran a reverse for a touchdown you know
again sam you know sammy watkins being
back in the lineup that gives the the
ability to send him deep and then tyree
kilcum underneath but the patriots are
always going to have to be aware of
where tyreek hill is at all times you've
heard their concerns about him it's hard
to replicate the speed that's why i go
with him
okay so i'm up i'm going now wait a
minute wait did you defer just to chris
or you've you've you've forfeited your
pick oh you're like the vikings in and
o4 no you go ahead all right my i'll
stay in that game my uh most important
non-qb in that game andy reid's brain so
andy reid can he jump over this hurdle
of playoff andy reid clock management
big game down in the fourth quarter run
the ball run the ball can he remember to
run the ball
will he be wearing shorts he's been
wearing shorts all week long it's an
absolutely crazy move andy reid's brain
is the most important non-qb in that
game to me
all right i'm gonna go to the other game
because there is an obvious name out
there and this is a legacy building game
for a guy that we have seen perform at a
high level he's been the best interior
defensive lineman of this generation one
of the best of all time maybe at least
the best since warren sapp and that is
the guy who now holds the single season
sack record for defensive tackles aaron
donald what he can do no matter how many
guys they use him what he can do to
disrupt that saints offense is going to
go a long way toward determining whether
or not the rams can end that streak i
think it's a nine-year streak of the
home team winning the nfc championship
game aaron donald is going to be the key
to slowing down the saints offense and
he is going to be critical to the
outcome of the game what a basic pitch
yeah i mean yeah of course i'm trying to
win this thing you know oh there's a
winner and loser well would you want me
one do you want me to pick you want me
to pick a punter
i mean johnny hecker is pretty good
right chris you're up next all right
thank you very much uh you know what i
am going to flip that on you and go with
andrus pete right off the bat because of
what you just said about the greatness
of aaron donald yes aaron donald is
great he can destroy football games but
i go with andrus pete because the first
time around the new orleans saints had
the luxury a lot of times and some big
moments to say you know what andrews
petey's our first round pick we think
he's a really damn good guard and we're
not going to help out and you know for
them listen aaron donald's always going
to make a few plays or get around the
quarterback for the most part though
andrus pete played very well in that
matchup and contained him there was no
sacks by the rams defense in that game
uh so i look at him again and i talked
about it earlier in the last segment
just saying how he kind of struggled
last week against fletcher cox and some
of the guys on the eagles if he does
that again this week and plays the way
he did in the divisional round and i
know he came off a late season
hand surgery
then they're going to be in deep crap in
new orleans so andrus pete is a guy i
look at is doing gonna have to have a
huge football game and they're gonna
have to be able to trust him in some
moments to handle aaron donald one on
one okay i don't think i'm doing this
draft right but i'm just gonna keep
charging through with my picks
my second pick is which sean thinks he
looks hotter on sunday because both
these guys now hear me out i'm gonna get
there i'm gonna convince both of you
remember when sean payton he had the
year off because of who you know we
won't talk about it we had the year off
he started doing crossfit he started
wearing shirts that were a little
tighter he thought he he looked really
good for his age sean mcvay has the hair
the perfectly manicured beard perfect
both these guys look in the mirror and
they say sean you're the number one sean
they do that in the morning every single
morning so i think they're going to be
looking across the field at each other
trying to one-up each other with play
calling and who can make the best play
call and the gadget plays if one of
these sean's lets their ego get a little
ahead of themselves and say i'm the
hotter sean that's where they'll fall
there there is some wisdom there
somewhere at the core of all of that
sean payton is the original i'm just
trying to win the game coach when he did
the onside kick surprise at the start of
the third quarter in super bowl 44. now
all of that type of rolling the dice is
commonplace and we're getting to the
point where maybe somebody's going to
try to be a little too cute and push a
little too far and take a chance that
becomes reckless i kind of like that
you're right it's sean mccabe trying to
outshine the other sean he did it sean
mcveigh did it last week when he should
have kicked the field goal to go up 11
and he goes for the touchdown which made
no sense whatsoever both sean's want to
be the best sean they're both think
they're hot sean's we'll see who who can
win that battle and to further your
point
i won this draft
i mean the fact that you're using brains
and hot shawn i mean that it is funny
and i think you see my third but no to
to the point though too sean mcvay kind
of did that in the first matchup the
game was 14-14 they had the ball and
they decided to go on a fake field goal
and they did not make it and the saints
got the ball back of course and went
right down the field and made it to 14
and the rams kind of lost control of the
game there where they were in the power
play so uh as funny as we're laughing at
the hot sean thing and all that uh there
is some wisdom here by by the big cat
yep
all right i'm gonna go back to being
extremely boring and conventional but
this is a guy that we're not talking
about much we mentioned him earlier in
the program because the last big play we
saw this year from rob gronkowski came
against the chiefs in week six at the
time he still had it this guy hasn't
fallen off a cliff and with some of
these guys you never know what injuries
they're really dealing with you know if
they never tell the team if they handle
it all on the side on their own with
alex guerrero or whoever you never know
that a guy's injured because the team
never knows he's actually injured maybe
gronk's been a little banged up and we
haven't really known it maybe gronk's
finally healthy again maybe gronk
understands that these may be the final
two games of his career this is a day
for rob gronkowski to show up in a big
way and it could be a long-term
rope-a-dope the patriots have engaged in
to make the chiefs think that gronk
isn't going to be gronk i think there's
a good chance gronk is going to be gronk
and if gronk can be grunk then the
patriots will have an easier time
advancing to the super bowl for what the
fourth time in five years
yeah i mean that's that's a i mean i i
i'm sorry i didn't have i'm sorry i
didn't have a more creative way to
present it i tried no it's okay uh you
did it right there i go you try to you
should have see a little tip for you a
little journalist tip you should have
said is this rob gorkowski's last game
in a patriots uniform that's how
i'm not aware of that i'm not aware of
that uh that possibility haven't heard
anything about that over the last year
certainly all right i mean certainly a
good a good one with gronkowski though
because he has not been the same and you
know even guys that are at his age the
skills are falling down can he rise up
to that occasion one more time in games
like this i would say yes i mean he's
truly you know this could make the blood
boil a little bit but eric barry could
be playing and eric barry gave him a
handful last year uh in that first match
up at the stage is that your pick is
that your own three kicks it's not
you're taking the hand off the check no
i'm not all right get around three okay
be quiet i'll pick it when i'm ready all
right here we go chris jones we have a
clock chris jones junior chris jones jr
okay that's we talk about aaron donald
for the rams and how important he is
this is the second best pass rushing
defensive tackle in all football chris
jones and his ability not only to stop
the run which we know the patriots want
to run the ball right but the other
thing we always hear about you know any
quarterback pressure in your face can
disrupt them we saw big tip passes by
chris jones last week and some third
downs on andrew luck and new england is
the king and i worked there and played
for josh mcdaniels for one year where
they want to say we want to clear the
pocket so then it becomes seven on seven
for the quarterback and chris jones can
ruin that whole plan if he can continue
to push the pocket into brady's face and
get pressure uh throughout the game
it's a good pick all right it's a good
pick it's a good pick all right my third
pick is gonna be uh the patriots
mystique because i think it matters in a
game like this the chiefs the the two
franchise franchises are polar opposites
in terms of success at the highest level
and if things go poorly for the chiefs
to start the game
we talked about it to be at the first
hour of the show the doubts start to
creep in not only on in in the sidelines
and on the staff and on the players but
in the stands and everything starts to
say oh no this is doom and gloom here we
go same old chiefs so i think the
patriots mystique and what they bring
with the brady belichick what are they
going to do what do they know what is
ernie adams figured out before this game
yeah right that all matters and that's
important
we were talking about this yesterday
it's actually a great pick because you
know
they're all great patriots they're all
great well well i'm just trying to be
polite what will the patriots do what
will they do to try to flummox and
confuse the chiefs and will it cause the
chiefs to overthink it well they start
seeing ghosts because they're thinking
oh the patriots are setting us up in
some way they have found something in
the film that that is trying to to dupe
us into doing this thing that's going to
get exposed somebody's going to jump up
and intercept the past they're showing
us something that we've never seen
before or we've seen it before and
they're going to execute it a different
way and i agree with you and and i think
that's a real dynamic in sports sure
when you feel like you just can't get
past someone when you feel like that
there's an edge that's built in if you
do get a head you start thinking it's
just a matter of time before the
floodgates open and it all falls apart
so i like that one there are so many
more left that i can choose from i want
to choose a i see i'm caught now i want
to choose a good traditional one versus
i want to come up with something
creative
you know what you're doing
don't try to be funny
yeah no you're mike foreign
be creative mike go ahead be funny tell
us a joke no i really i'm not i don't
really have anything
i'm going to go i'm going to go with
todd gurley for the reasons we discussed
earlier not just when he has the ball
but when he doesn't have the ball oh
here he gets frustrated what will he get
frustrated if cj anderson is getting a
bunch of touches will there be any
friction on the side i'm telling you fox
keep a camera on todd gurley if the
saints are ahead early and the rams
aren't moving the ball and cj anderson
is getting roughly the same number of
attempts as todd gurley i want a camera
on todd gurley and i want to see if that
facade cracks because i think the rams
are trying very hard to make sure todd
gurley doesn't blow his stack because
he's gone from being mvp candidate to
part-time player in his own backfield
and i think it's some level that's got
to be bothering him mike it's all in the
selling of it you need to say todd
gurley's me first attitude is the most
non-import non-qb important player in
the championship see he knows all like
the barstool social you know it's hazy
happiness yeah todd gurley's unhappiness
with uh sean mcvay is the most important
storyline going into sunday oh you guys
todd gurley's massive ego sarah in the
box yeah gigantic it might not even fit
in the dome
all right let's recap this thing and
move on chris sims has tyree kill andrus
pete chris jones big cat has andy reed's
brain whichever sean thinks he looks
hotter that day and the patriots
mystique i've got aaron donald gronk and
todd gurley uh big cat wins all right
this is the first time
big cat wins yeah that's good i think
you've revolutionized this whole draft
process you're right i think we need to
be sillier going forward yeah we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna step it up
to a new level if we can we'll find out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports